انتهت فترة التوقف الآن، دعونا ننزلق مرة أخرى،
كلاب
الحرب لا تزال على قيد الحياة، يصرخ أحدهم بينما يتم
حمل طفل بعيدًا عن أنقاض
منزل مختبئ في
رع في هان يون، يتم نقل أطفال هان يون
إلى جناح الطوارئ وفقًا لتقديرات الأمم المتحدة، ما
يقرب من 40٪ من
سكان غزة  لقد قُتل بالفعل أقل من 15
ألف طفل،
ويجب أن يتوقف هذا عن النداءات،
المتحدث باسم اليونيسف، جيمس إلدر من
مستشفى رافا، لا يمكننا رؤية المزيد من الأطفال الذين يعانون من
جروح الحرب والحروق والشظايا التي
تتناثر على أجسادهم
والعظام المكسورة أثناء القتال.  من قبل أصحاب
النفوذ هو السماح بقتل
الأطفال، هذه حرب على الأطفال،
جاءت جهود الوساطة لتمديد الهدنة لعدم استمرار إسرائيل في تحقيق
هدفها المتمثل في تدمير حماس، فقط كن
أكثر حذرا أثناء القيام بذلك،
حث وزير الخارجية الأمريكي أنتوني بلينكين على
نؤكد أنا والإسرائيليون على ضرورة
عدم تكرار الخسائر الفادحة في أرواح المدنيين والتهجير بالحجم الذي رأيناه في
شمال غزة في جنوب غزة بحلول
مساء الجمعة، حيث تجاوز عدد القتلى
منذ الصباح
170 شخصًا وفقًا لتقديرات غزة.  تدير وزارة الصحة التابعة لحركة حماس
إضافة إلى ما يقرب من 15.000
قتيل قبل
الهدنة، جاء هذا الرجل إلى
المستشفى المعمداني في مدينة غزة بحثًا عن
أخيه الصغير زاد ليجده في
جثة،
وهو يبكي على
الهاتف داخل المسعفين.  لإنقاذ
حياة فتاة تبلغ من العمر عامين
أصيبت بجروح خطيرة في
غارة إسرائيلية، لا تزال هناك فرصة
لتجديد الهدنة إذا تمكنت حماس وإسرائيل من
التوصل إلى اتفاق جديد،
فلا يستطيع شعب غزة تحمل
الانتظار بن ويدمان  سي إن إن
القدس